Instructor: In the
next couple of videos, we're
going to learn all about
promises. In order to get the
most out of these lessons, you
need to know two things. First
of all, promises are often used
when you're fetching a JSON API
and doing some AJAX work.
Here I've got my wesbos.com JSON
API, and I'm pulling in a list
of blog posts. Second, I'm going
to be using a thing called Fetch
to be able to fetch in this JSON
API. That's not a library or
anything, it's a thing that's
built right into the browser. It
also returns a promise. If
you haven't heard of Fetch
before, it's very similar to
dollar.getJSON if you've used
jquery before, or dollar.AJAX,
or any of these other AJAX
libraries. Except, rather than
having to load an external
library, it's going to be built
right into the browser.
Knowing that, let's jump into
some examples of promises. What
is a promise? A promise is
something that will happen
between now and the end of time.
A really nice way to think of
that is something that will
happen in the future, but
probably not immediately. In
order to understand this, we
need to be reminded that
JavaScript is almost entirely
asynchronous, which means that
if we take some code here...
Let's take a look at the example.
I'm console.logging, going to
fetch the latest posts. I am
going to fetch the post from my
blog right here. I'm going to
attempt to store those posts in
a post variable console.log done,
and console.log the posts.
What happens when we refresh
this? We see going to fetch,
done immediately. How can we see
both of these immediately? Then,
if we console.log the posts, we
don't actually see the actual
data inside of it. That's
really important, because this
right here, Fetch, it queues up
the search. It goes over to
wesbos.com and tries to fetch
the posts immediately, but it
does not just store them in your
post variable. That might be
different if you're coming from
another language like PHP, where
you will just stop everything
from running. This will just
queue it up and put inside of
posts, not the post, but it puts
what's called a promise. Which
means like, "Hey, I don't have
the data from it just yet, but
here's a little IOU the posts
from Wes's blog. When they do
come back, I'll be sure to let
you know about that." Let me
get rid these console.logs here.
I'm going to rename this post
variable to posts promise. This
promise, we can then listen to
it. We can say, post promise.
then. We're sort of in normal,
where we have a link, and we'd
say onClick, and only when we
click does the code here get run.
We'll be able to do like, alert,
hey. That's what's called a
callback, and that callback will
run only when someone clicks it.
It's the same thing here, where
we have a then function that
will only run when the data
comes back. The then function
will give us the data. We can
run a little arrow function here,
and I'm just going to console.
log the data to see what we've
got. Open this up, there we
go. It looks like we have a
response here. Because when the
data comes back...let me save it
again already. One, two, and
then after two seconds it
actually comes back. Then you
see here, this looks like some
good data that I've got. You've
got some headers and the body.
That's probably what we want.
Where are my posts? Well, it
does bring back the actual raw
data, but it doesn't yet know
that we're expecting JSON,
because you could fetch any type
of data, not just JSON. What
we can do from there is just, we
return data.JSON. Or you're
probably looking at this, we
could probably just do an
implicit return like the first
videos, which is data.JSON. You
can attach another .then onto
that. Let's see what that data
gives us, .log data. One,
two, OK. That took a second
there. Give it another save, and
bam. They show up after two
seconds. Open it up, and there
is the actual data that comes
back from our blog. You see
there's the content, there's the
excerpt, "super excited to
announce," etc., etc. We
have the good data here. Now, a
couple of things we can do here
is, probably you want to format
it a little bit, something like
this, where you can chain .thens
together. Often people will put
them on their own line, just for
readability's sake. Second of
all, there is another thing that
we need to listen to, and that
is what's called a catch. The
then will only fire when the
promise successfully comes back,
but what if there is an error
with the data that comes back?
That's where the catch actually
runs. Generally, you say .
then, .then. That's all of your
thens that you need. It might be
one, it might be four. Then we
have a catch on the end that
will just catch any errors that
happen anywhere along the way.
That's going to give us an error
here, console.error. We can
console.log that actual error.
Let's see what we've got here.
Now it's working, but if I were
to break this like, doJASON. I
don't know how to spell it.
There we go. We've got our error
here. There's some other errors
that happened, but this is the
one that actually gets thrown by
this catch block here. Type
error failed to actually do the
fetching. That is Fetch at a
very high level. Let's dive into
it a little bit deeper, and see
how we can create our own.